welcome to bananamores i
seriously go bananas for this guy
that's why he's perfect for bananamores
welcome back to jimmy kimmel live i'm
jimmy kimmel
i'm the jimmy that you watch when fallon
is too much
drew barrymore is one of the most
beloved personalities and actors of all
time
here with us today are some celebrities
that want to share that love
first up seth rogen
you know my first movie was withdrew
barrymore it was uh donnie darko
really freaky movie her production
company flower films produced it
pretty awesome right and as you know i
love plants
if you know what i mean
[Laughter]
uh yeah seth i think we all know what
you mean
vince vaughn what do you think
you know drew barrymore is one of the
greatest actors of all time if you don't
believe that
that that's crazy you know you know i
could have been in the wedding singer as
well but instead i was in swingers
you see what i did there you know it's
pretty clever it's pretty you know i
actually love the 80s you know i could
have actually been in the wedding singer
because i love devo i love the hats you
know that's the thing about ohio
yeah let me stop you right there vince
we only have so much time on this show
uh nick offerman what do you think
the name drew barrymore evokes
quality beauty and dependability
much like a fine mahogany kayak or a
smooth age scotch wow nick offerman a
real handyman you know we actually built
my porch
true story uh robert downey jr
uh yeah hi uh you know drew and i were
80s party kids that only grew up to be
uh beloved you know adults a very
chilled out
namaste uh you're great i'm great
uh there's nothing to debate thank you
all right and finally we have john hamm
[Laughter]
jon hamm drew barrymore
two very attractive people
deal with it short and sweet ham i love
it
uh well that's all the time that we have
for tonight's show
drew you're amazing we love you and my
apologies to matt damon for not getting
to him in time
all right see you later good night
a banana loss instant legend the banana
more stage is
lucky to have that one i'll tell ya oh
what a treat